he's getting impeached for a border
that's breached the house gearing up for
a vote on the impeachment of DHS
secretary Alejandro
mayorcas and we could get that very soon
Republicans accuse mayorcas of failing
to enforce the law and lying to Congress
while Republicans blame my orcus Joe
Biden is now trying to place the blame
for his border disaster on you guessed
it Trump Joe is pushing Congress to pass
the proposed Senate deal for border
security that as of right now is dead
than a hair follicle on Jesse's scalp
all indications are this bill won't even
move forward to the senate floor why a
simple reason Donald Trump because
Donald Trump thinks it's bad for him
politically he'd rather weaponize this
issue then actually Solve IT frankly
they owe it to the American people to
show some spine the Republicans have to
decide who do they serve Donald Trump or
the American people every day between
now and November the American people are
going to know
that the only reason the border is not
secure is Donald Trump and his Maggie
Republican friends folks we've got to
move past his toxic politics he's worse
than Tom shaloo the deuce letting loose
on kjp on whether Dems bear
responsibility for an action on the
border while they controlled the house
you guys talk a lot including today
about how the Border wouldn't be such a
big deal if Congress would have just
passed your immigration bill on day one
who was in charge of Congress on day one
we have said is that Congress has to act
right Congress Democrats Republicans
have to act but in those three years it
is true that Republicans have gotten in
the way I mean they voted they've
actually voted two years no responsibil
it has I'm not saying that Democrats
have not been in control the first two
years that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying House Republicans have got in the
way and house Speaker Mike Johnson is
holding the line that the Border bill is
DOA it was supposed to have a border
security uh set of Provisions in it that
is not what we got we got a supplemental
funding Proposal with immigration
Provisions it's not a border security
bill it doesn't do uh anything of the
sort Republicans simply cannot vote for
the bill in good conscience and that is
why I declared it Dead on Arrival and it
looks like right now it may be in some
Jeopardy it may be on life support in
the Senate um we welcome that
development Jesse in this process C this
impeachment inquiry and so on what if we
find out that mayorcas isn't really
incompetent at all it's just that he's F
he's good at following orders following
orders from who exactly Taylor Swift
maybe she's behind everything you know
or the cartels I would say the cartels
and Taylor Swift working in conjunction
with the space aliens congrats you're
booked on Jesse wat's prime time in
the so we looked it up any president
since 1952 can shut shut down the Border
says it right here whenever he finds an
entry of aliens is detrimental to the
United States he can shut the whole
thing down like that so he's asking
Congress for Powers he already has and
20 million 20 billion do so what's the
money for well it's just basically to
hire an army of lawyers nonprofit and
Asylum officers to just continue to
facilitate the open borders and then he
locks in a DC District Court rubber
stamp which is farle to just say
whatever anybody wants to challenge is
either bogus or legit now the Border
never closes that's not Jesse Waters
saying that that's the co-author of this
bill the senator from Connecticut this
whole 5,000 thing okay here's how it
works 5,000 come in for a week right it
averages that they don't shut the border
down they just funnel all of the entries
into the Port of Entry and they bring
them in that way and then what happens
if you show up at another part in the
Border if you claim it it's an emergency
they still have to let you in they don't
actually even detain anybody in this
bill because they only asked for 15,000
additional beds so if you can't detain
how are you going to deport and how is
Bush and Obama and Trump deporting
hundreds of thousands of migrants a year
with less money than Biden and Biden
needs more money and this is the tough
screening process are you scared yes did
you find a place to Mexico that you
could stay no you're in it's a joke and
they only have $25 million to fight
cartels but they give $400 million to
lawyers that's how you know they're not
serious about this this whole thing is
designed to keep the status quo they've
legislated the status quo nothing in
here is going to stop a single person
from coming in and they're just doing
this so Joe Biden can claim credit to
solve a problem that he created in the
first place this thing makes it worse
I'm glad it's DOA well done you just
basically killed the bill yourself judge
you know it's interesting to hear Joe
Biden blame Trump trump won in 2016 On
the Border he was the toughest person on
the border and now it's all going to
hell and of course Biden who has trumped
derangement on you know anabolic
steroids uh do you think that that's
going to
sell the truth is that Joe Biden is the
one who reversed the Border policies
where we had some of the lowest number
of immigrants coming through uh by
immediately on day one indicating his
intent to the American people that he
wanted an open border policy that's what
he did and for him to blame Trump I mean
he's got Trump derangement syndrome
Trump said it in spite of the fact that
for four years the Democrats fought with
Trump trump fought with them built a
wall had all kinds of uh restrictions
and at the end the last month he was
there was 70,000 who came in and
December um of that year of of and now
Joe Biden has over 300,000 and we've got
known and unknown Goda ways but this
bill is not a border bill it's an
immigration Bill Jesse is right this is
all about making sure that we have
enough uh people to be able to process
the illegals to get them through the
legal ports of Entry all the things that
Trump didn't have Trump didn't have this
kind of money Trump had the law that
Jesse just referenced that I have too
you can arrest them you don't need to do
anything else and you know Biden is
talking about money to close the border
he doesn't think about the fact that
that what is it costing us to not fix
the Border it's costing us in terms of
deaths of Americans it's costing us we
just found out $23 million in credit
cards in New York City alone for um
illegals expenses to the states uh as
well as hospitals going under schools
that are being overrun it's all about
willpower Texas has it
Biden doesn't have it and in the
end Biden would rather weaponize this
thing than solve the problem this is a
National Emergency he won't treat it as
such he's only worried about giving uh
20 million On the Border 60 million to
Ukraine why is that and finally let me
just say that more Asylum officers and
Expediting work permits and allowing an
increased numbers of visas he says it's
going to be the toughest and fairest
bill on immigration ever but to
not to Americans but to the illegals
Dana you know we're regular Americans we
get up in the morning we have our
breakfast you know polish our Gucci bags
um don't you feel that underlying all of
this is a mistrust in the system yeah
that it's like we can't take these
things seriously anymore because they
wait till the last minute when there's
an election and then they voice this
monstrosity on us and say read it over
the weekend and you get back to us as
soon as possible and if you don't agree
you're a Traer that just makes everybody
say stop I think also it's that there's
a lot of people that don't trust it even
if they were to get this Authority that
Biden would follow through so there's
that piece of it as well I also thought
that when Biden came out and said the
only reason the border is not secure is
Donald Trump that it sounded like when
they tried to blame Republicans for
defunding the police and nobody bought
it and it was like five pinocchios or
however many pinocchios you could get
there the NBC poll over the weekend
showed that Republicans have a
Point advantage of President Biden on
immigration but make no mistake like
they the the Democrats now have a a
messaging line they will beat it it be
they will beat that line to death yeah
and this bill is dead so I we don't have
to go over the points over and over
again the bill is not going forward so
now the question is will they impeach my
orcus will Biden do anything and will he
be able to actually somehow say that
it's magga Republicans they they think
that they can further drw drive a wedge
between mag whoever they're calling Maga
Republicans and someone like Senator
Langford who's from Oklahoma and one of
the most conservative people in the
Senate so I I am not for animal cruelty
and I will not beat this horse to death
anymore all right Harold you know this
is a border bill but it's not our border
is it we're spending three times as much
money on Ukraine and you got Chuck
Schumer saying you know if we don't vote
on this bill you know Young Americans
are going to fight in Europe you know
your kids are going to croak if you
don't do this that's a bit of Hyperbole
and I think you should disown it
immediately Harold I have a slightly
different point of view I I I I start
with the editorial board of our one of
our in-house newspapers called The Wall
Street Journal and starts saying do
Republicans want to better secure the US
border they want to keep what has become
an open sore festering for another year
as an election issue I think that's a
question that a lot of Voters are going
to answer uh in November and but they're
wrong The Wall Street Journal is wrong
we'll see we'll see what side people
come down on this bill has been endorsed
this this negotiated bill this
compromised which is be the word
compromis in politics has become um such
a bad word unfortunately when our whole
nation was founded on a compromise but
that's a a different different
conversation the border of Patrol Union
and US Chamber of Commerce have endorsed
this bill now when I think about some of
those who argue and there have been
Republicans who've openly said in
Congress that if they pass this bill
let's a get out of jail free card for
President Biden or will help him in
election it reminded me of how silly and
unpatriotic a group of Democrats would
sound if a Republican president were to
pass gun reform legislation uh in an
election year and Democrats in Congress
and the Senate would say we can't allow
this uh woman who would be president of
the United States because she's a
republican to pass this bill because
it's going to help her get reelected in
the fall I would be a Democrat saying
you're crazy uh we fought for this for a
long time the greatest advocates for
this uh for Border reform and Board of
security have been around this table uh
and have been around around our country
including a lot of Republicans I think
and for republicans in Congress to deny
their constituents and to to deny the
American people an open debate about
this on the house floor and the senate
floor uh I think is an abomination in
many ways you don't get everything you
want in life certainly not in politics
this bill here has historic has historic
wins for those of us who want different
and better and security different
security and better security at our
border is it perfect no nothing is
perfect uh this here however pushes us
way down way down the line now I would
ask those who genuinely believe and I
you can have this genuine belief that if
president Trump is elected that there
will be a different kind of Border Bill
uh I don't know if that would be the
case I think the kind of negotiated the
kind of negotiations and the kind of
compromise that have been reached here
by Senator lenford and others is
something that may not be attained six
seven eight nine 10 months down the road
and I would say in in closing for those
of us who are concerned about fentel
human trafficking terrorists all the
things that happened here in New York
City with cops being beat up uh we're
going to allow it to happen for nine to
10 more months uh because of politics to
me bid allowed it to happen for two and
a half years I'll agree with you let's
say I agree with you I'll stipulate that
so why should we let it happen for 10
more months because the Border stay
because Joe can stop it The Wall Street
Journal the border patrol Union the
Chamber of Commerce all Endor this we
should pass this I think when I think
we've just been burned so many times
with things that are called something
like the inflation reduction act and
it's not inflation reduction at all it's
climate nonsense I just think you know
why don't we have the time to take the
bill apart you know and follow the logic
behind each decision we don't instead we
are told if we don't do this we're
Hypocrites no we have to be able to pick
it up take a look at it I want to see
what's in the shopping cart before I buy
it I don't disagree with which is why
they should bring it to the floor and
let's amend it they should make the
changes that they want to it and then
send it back to the Senate okay and
you're wrong you are perfect
you said nothing is perfect all right hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now